TODD KERPELMAN: Hello.
I'm Todd Kerpelman for
The Developer Show.
This is your weekly update
on the coolest developer
news from Google.
Android Q Beta 2--
hey, that rhymes-- is now
available along with an updated
SDK.
Included in this release
are privacy features
for testing and
feedback, a new way
to multitask with bubbles, a
foldables emulator, and more.
For more details
and screenshots,
take a look at the post.
The Lustre open source
parallel file system
allows you to access
large amounts of data
at extremely high
speeds and low latency.
But configuring it
is a technically
challenging and
time-consuming task.
So we've released some scripts
to help you easily deploy
a Lustre storage cluster--
ooh, that rhymes too--
on Google Compute Engine using
the Google Cloud Deployment
Manager.
To get started, head
on over to the post.
Cloud Healthcare API
offers a managed solution
for storing and accessing
healthcare data in Google Cloud
Platform, providing a critical
bridge between existing care
systems and applications
hosted on Google Cloud.
And it is now available in beta.
Links to get started
are on the post.
Compute Optimized VMs
and Memory Optimized VMs
will be available for
Google Compute Engine.
Both are based on
second-generation Intel Xeon
Scalable Processors.
A link to sign up for early
access is on the post.
Language Identification
and Smart Reply
are now available for ML Kit.
Example code and
a link to the docs
are, you guessed
it, on the post.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Todd Kerpelman for
"The Developer Show."
Thanks for watching, and
we'll see you next week.
Ha, I'm just going to
smile like I got something
that I'm excited about.